[Musique]
g
et
bonjour aune de tocqueville bonjour
merci d'être sur le plateau de tv 78
vous êtes là parce que vous êtes la
commissaire d'une magnifique exposition
qui a lieu en ce moment au musée
lambinet et dont le sujet et georges
gazte alors elle s'intitule un orient
sans mirage et la lieu jusqu'au 18
février donc musée lambinet à versailles
évidemment donc vous êtes la commissaire
de cette exposition
mais pas que vous êtes avant tout
écrivain pouvait voir venir un tout
petit peu en arrière donc peut-être
écrivain depuis toujours vous êtes un
écrivain qui aime beaucoup voyager j'ai
l'impression a dit que je passe une
frontière je suis contente voilà est
votre dernier livre alors qu'il ya
beaucoup de succès comment
s'appelle-t-il alors il s'appelle atlas
des cités perdues chez arthaud et c'est
génial parce que je crois que les gens
adorent qu'on leur raconte des histoires
et il raconte les histoires des villes
abandonnées dans le monde à toutes les
époques et sur tous les continents dans
lesquels vous êtes à l'aise assure
parfois mais il ya une ville engloutie
ce marché comprend bon ok ensuite vous
n'êtes pas du tout une commissaire
habituellement vous êtes une banque en
une écrivain comme on vient de le dire
et vous avez il vous arrive est une
drôle de rencontre
j'ai vraiment eu beaucoup de chance j'ai
rencontre je suis tombé vraiment par
hasard il ya quelques années sur les
archives de ce peintre orientaliste qui
s'appelle george best est way et j'ai eu
vraiment un coup de foudre pour sa
peinture est aussi pour l'homme qu'il
était parce que dans ces archives il y
avait
une correspondance incroyable de cet
homme avec son petit cousin germain et
je me suis dit faut vraiment que
j'écrive quelque chose sur ce peintre
qui est tombé dans l'oubli pendant 100
ans et parce que ça je peux vous dire
pourquoi face est déposée par ben
pourquoi est ce que c'est un excellent
peintre mais comme c'était un homme très
sauvage très maigre c'est pour ça que
j'ai bien aimé cet homme là et il est
mort en inde du sud à 41 ans donc
vraiment très loin de paris 1910 c'était
la fin de l'orientalisme donc en 1910 et
donc il y avait tous les mouvements
picturaux qui émergeait à ce moment là
et il a été comme il était très sauvage
il a été suivi par aucun marchand comme
durand ruel et tout ça donc il était
tout seul il est mort
l'extrait à l'extrémité sud de l'inde
est donc au bout du compte les y ait eu
la première guerre mondiale et ses
archives sont restés dans chez quelqu'un
de sa famille pendant 100 ans
là où vous les avez trouvés y trouver
les archives et quelques tableaux
j'imagine il y avait c'est ça quand je
ferme à des adulescents je suis tombé en
arrêt devant un petit gamin un doute
était magnifique et j'ai demandé à la
dame qui avait cette maison mais qui a
peint ce tableau et la dame m'a dit oh
un artiste de la famille qu avait
mauvaise réputation qui est mort
solitaire en inde alors évidemment ça
titille et mme allard est passé et elle
m'a légué ses archives et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya quatre ans je me suis dit
j'arrête les autres livres que je t'aime
en train d'écrire et je pars sur ses
traces d'accord donc il faut savoir que
cette peintre il est parti vivre tout
d'abord en algérie après 1,4 en algérie
4 en egypte et après en inde où
malheureusement il est mort à 40 ans 41
ans
en 1910 voilà alors vous vous l'avez
suivi comment ça s'est passé pour écrire
cette bio fait vous vous êtes dit je
vais écrire c'est jason wu wei
bah oui il y aura l'expo voilà donc je
me suis dit il faut vraiment que j'aille
que je prenne des photocopies très
concrète de ces tableaux et de ces
photos parce que je ne vous ai pas
oublié ça mais horde plongeant dans ses
archives
je suis tombé sur un trésor qui étaient
deux boîtes en bois qui contenait 250
plaques de verre des petits pois de
velde
oui c'était formidable je les ai enlevés
de la boîte je les ai fait développer et
là des merveilles absolue d'une
modernité incroyable parce que gasté qui
avaient un oeil de peintre il vivait au
milieu des populations locales
les colons l'emmerdait été complètement
immergé met donc ces photos sont son
incroyable dans ce sont vraiment des
instantanés de la verte ou rurale ne
l'est pas en algérie et en inde à ce que
les photos égyptienne on était pas
disparu d'accord oui c'est autant un
photographe qu'un peintre
oui alors vous définissez comme peintre
bien sûr alors peut-être que je le
trahit en montrant ses photos mais ces
photos sont tellement belle que ayant
plus elles ont elles ressemblent enfin
je trouve qu'il a un double regard et
c'est très très lié en fait son regard
de photographe et son regard de peintre
d'accord donc vous partez sur ses traces
donc en algérie vous organiser des
expositions déjà pas du tout donc je
quand je reviens de ses voyages donc
j'ai passé quelques mois plongé aussi
dans des archives et j'ai écrit ce livre
donc chez arthaud qui s'avéra qu'est le
soleil dans l'ombre et je me suis dit je
peux pas sortir un livre comme ça d'un
peintre inconnu sans faire une
exposition aurait été un peu frustrant
pour les genres merci absolument voilà
et donc j'ai découvert le métier de
commissaire d'exposition qui est
formidable et en mars 2013 j'ai réalisé
donc cette première exposition sur gasté
au musée du montparnasse à paris
et là des commissaires priseurs mon
10mai m'ont presque engueuler ou dire
mais comment on connaît pas ce peintre
sa formidable fautes bêtes n'ont qu'à
l'époque mais et de la route
donc là dessus après comme je m'amuse
toujours face je vous suis dit mon petit
défi c'est d'aller montrer ses photos en
algérie et en inde
et j'ai vu vraiment des indiens pleurer
devant ces photos parce que l'inde s'est
elle est un peu immuable c'est
formidable de voir la plongée dans
l'indiana en temps de gast et pour eux
c'était extraordinaire
paya oui oui oui tout à fait et quand
j'ai voyagé en inde je peux vous dire
qu'il ya une permanence du temps passé
comme incroyable et on algérie aussi
donc vous avez organisé des expositions
là bas oui d'accord de photos je veux
tourner le blues c'est un peu compliqué
ouais très bien et donc après et depuis
donc quand je suis en bien et en 2013 et
j'ai organisé une autre exposition au
musée mandet de riom et j'ai rencontré
tout à fait par hasard il ya un an
directeur des affaires culturelles de la
ville de versailles a vraiment dans un
marais à paris
ouais absolument et qui m'a dit qu'il
cherchait quelqu'un enfin il avait envie
d'animer un peu le musée lambinet
d'organes est oui a dit qu'il est
l'oriental y semer mais déjà avait déjà
été exposées juste avant donc ça faisait
une saison absolument pas débutée alors
regardez juste derrière vous à côté bref
nous voyons un premier tableau
est-ce que vous pouvez nous que le monte
sur la wii gasquet a passé quatre ans à
boussaâda oui hélas ces deux petits gars
c'est la jungle juste à côté oui c'est
en algérie bousada c'est une oasis à 300
km au sud d'alger et 7
c'est un ravissant tableau c'est aussi
voilà deux petits garçons qui regarde
d'ailleurs un mur c'est tout à fait
charmant et on voit que gasté ne part
pas du tout comme beaucoup
d'orientalistes qu'on appelle académique
en fin de salon
il parle pas des scènes deux arrêts
des scènes de chasse de fantasia et ils
pensent vraiment à l'avenir s'est il dit
toujours je y recherche jusqu'à
l'obsession fait la réalité et la vérité
et l'émotion et l'émotion mission il est
moche mais c'est pour ça que ces
portraits sont magnifiques des couëts
d'accord là justement on envoie toute
une galerie
donc ça aussi sondé algérienne je crois
alors dans cette salle 2 du musée
lambinet j'ai voulu vraiment mettre une
série de portraits de jeunes algériennes
et d'insister sur les regards parce que
s'est il dit toujours il veut vraiment
aller jusqu'à l'obsession d'aller donc
je disais 2010 la couleur locale ça ne
m'intéresse pas et je veux vraiment
essayé de capter l'âme de l'umam de mes
modèles
donc je trouve que c'est portraits sont
très touchants et à ce que vous avez
fait aussi c'est de faire exploser en
parallèle cinq artistes contemporains ja
oui
après deux expositions je me suis dit je
vais pas recommencer la même exposition
et je trouvais ça très intéressant de
déplier l'oeuvre de gast et de l'ouvrir
à aujourd'hui
et là alors là ces artistes
contemporains ont fait un cadeau
incroyable parce que en travaillant sur
gasté alors il y en a un pour vous
donner un exemple qui partit en inde
avec qui a posé sa came c'est un
vidéaste qui s'appelle jean de boysson
et il a posé sa caméra là où gasté avait
mis le trépied d'un appareil
photographique et il a filmé sans bouger
que
la vie en inde est vraiment à l'endroit
où gast était allé et là le résultat est
saisissant pas ce qu'on voit à la fois
la permanence de l'inde
et puis aussi on voit à quel point les
photographies de gast et son
cinématographique ça mais presque les
photos de rester en mouvement
donc ça c'est formidable et puis il ya
un autre un autre artiste qui s'appelle
luc de cointe et qui a créé une oeuvre
picturale à partir d'une photo de gasté
et elle aimait zen contemplative et oui
c'est j'ai vu des petites jeunes filles
algériennes s'asseoir sur la banquette
devant cette oeuvre elle est absolument
sublime et elle est la femme
je ne sais pas c'est cette exposition je
voulais vraiment qu'elles sont un peu
contraint contempler à l'extérieur- oui
elle est mystérieuse et contemporaine
est vivante et hors norme finalement
parce que on aime ou non voitures prises
en surprises et ce peintre qui m'a alors
en fait le problème de ce peintre que
george best est une ville appelée gaston
mais ces questions c'est georges bref il
n'était pas en très grande forme
il souffrait de mélancolie oui il a
toujours c'était quelqu'un qui était
hyper sensible trois solitaires il avait
eu une enfance un peu difficile il avait
du mal à se confronter aux autres donc à
la fois pendant tous ces voyages il
voulait toujours être reconnu et là on
voit une photo ap là on voyait regardez
cette photo elle est surtout cote quand
on est un européen et qu'on est à
boussaâda la ctu dans une rue de bou
saâda c'est les enfants qui courent vers
vous évidemment les femmes restent chez
elles c'est pour ça qu'il l'a pas fait
pas mal raconté d'enfants tout à fait
donc le pauvre il souffrait donc de
mélancolie et du coup ça a fait qui sait
qu'il a vécu un peu en sauvage entre
guînes il est vécu une semaine en 1907
trois ans avant de mourir il était
devenu vraiment le peintre des impôts
parce que son petit cousin exposés comme
ses toiles qui m'a aidé à tout même à
whitney qui arrivait oui les toiles
arrivée dans les salon des artistes
français ou de paris regardez cette
photo du pouvoir le voit à droite vous
avez la terrasse de sita c'est la
terrasse il habitait là et là pendant
deux ans on est en inde à agra à 800 800
mètres à vol d'oiseau du taj mahal que
vous voyez je trouve que cette photo est
vraiment symbolique de l'offre de gaz t
elle et d'une mélancolie absolue elle
est belle elle est on voit la rivière
comme ça je trouve que cette photo est
également magnifique et cette faillite
fifa cette photo on la retrouve
dans des toiles il dans une île à une
sanguine à partir de cette photo
d'accord parce qu'en fait ils se
servaient quelquefois de ces photos pour
faire des tableaux alors rarement
rarement la faute aux cervelles c'était
pour se détendre mais effectivement il
ya quelques photos qu'il a lens aruna un
autre portrait voilà vous aviez le sahel
et elle est magnifique cette jeune femme
hindous qui vous regarde avec un regard
un peu un peu sauvage si je la trouve
très belle
d'accord donc en fait pluie il a gardé
un lien avec l'occident par son cousin
et puis il se trouve que sa vie s'est
terminée très tôt et tristement
finalement parce qu'il l'a souffre elle
a souffert d'un manque de rue oui mais
pourtant il était très connu un sens
vraiment je tiens à le dire puisque j'ai
eues dans les archives il a eu quand
même de rétrospective au grand palais
après sa mort c'est pas rien mais il est
arrivé une histoire fait un peu triste
quand il est arrivé dans le sud de
l'inde
deux ans avant de mourir il a découvert
un une ville extraordinaire s'appelle
mode du raï qui se trouve qu'il est
vraiment la capitale d'un hindouiste
assez fort il ya une immense temple
amadu rails et dans ce temple de madura
il ya un bassin qui s'appelle le bassin
du lotus dehors et il a passé neuf mois
à peindre cette ce bassin et il a fait
un tableau magnifique qui appartient
aujourd'hui au musée d'orsay et que vous
pourrez vous pouvez voir au musée
lambinet génial oui oui absolument et
vous l'avez vue là il est passé il ya
trois secondes et il s'est dit là je
vais avoir une reconnaissance absolue
des sondeurs voilà son ce bateau ce tout
ce tableau est arrivé au salon des
orientalistes de 1910 il était encensée
par la critique parce que j'ai tout les
tous les articles
mais il n'a pas été récompensé et là je
crois que ça a été c'est allongé as le
haut et ses talents et on l'a retrouvé
mort il est alité sans manger sans boire
c'est vrai elle s'est laissée mourir de
déception espèce de suicides m'a écouté
je pense que maintenant il est très très
contents mais travail que vous avez fait
alors j'en suis
et ben c'est un excellent peintre un vab
ou et merci beaucoup merci de
tocqueville et ballon vite voir cette
magnifique exposition très riche et est
très intéressante magnifique merci
odeurs au revoir
[Musique]